what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba I
am John Humphrey we are going to watch
Supernatural season 3 bloopers because
at our patreon we have made it to season
four Beibei and it's been awesome at our
patreon we do weekly Q&A zand we also do
TV show reaction stream alongs for
several shows some of them are complete
them are in progress right now and those
are Cobra Kai season two hunting a hill
house season one Gotham just May it's a
season for there stranger things season
3 agents of shield there are several
shows that we have stream alongs for the
reason stream along me you sync up with
the timecode there's also the option for
these ones where we do reaction
highlights included so 10 minutes worth
footage include its you don't worry
about the syncing up and those are super
natural of course our most viewed show
over at patreon
attack on Titan Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood we are continuing my hero
academia this week season for baby but
we also covered the movie as well Death
Note coat yes one punch man hunter
hunter and he does music video coverage
weekly
so yeah let's watch these bloopers now
that season 3 is done
[Music]
mr. Bluebird
[Music]
I'm sorry I thought I just heard you say
you were stupid enough
[Music]
a whole episode like this oh yeah it's
my new photo that was it I got a line
you [ __ ] I'm not one in a million and
I'm the very bad side
roll again
[Music]
they're a lot more comfortable with each
other yeah that like zoo oh that's
green-screen head
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Thanks
[Music]
[Music]
I love that episode episode all right
[Laughter]
oh good times they'll realize after
they're done filming season 3 I think
Jared Padalecki went down to his
favorite bar in Texas mm-hmm and was on
great behavior definite all time
definitely didn't get any altercations
yeah never was on TMZ and nor will he
ever be ever we do not need to cancel
Jared paddle I know not you saying that
the latest on that do we delay saw that
it was like drunk he was he was pretty
out of line but he was like I saw the
TMZ baby was pretty like Wayland it
wasn't just like he had a few drinks he
was we was wasted the best behavior did
not come out of him getting in fights
fighting he misses I don't saving people
hunting things I live in Texas butters
is like yeah my friends from Texas this
seems like a Texas weekend Texas Texas
bar anyways I know five or some guys
friends of his - I don't really over the
details but I just I just remember
reading it and then go people know me
castle Volta yeah when I heard he was in
the news I was like oh no and then I
loved all the circumstances I was like
yeah I mean bad behavior yeah a good
salad this is hope this is not a problem
but at the same time this doesn't seem
like out of hand
bar brawl whatever black soul offense
yeah hey watching this is great so you
do see a difference actually because we
watched the season two bloopers a couple
months ago watching this one there is a
difference they did seem like they were
having fun and they were comfortable
with each other but they seem
exceptionally more loose by the time
they read season three the way they
interact with the crew how they interact
with each other that whole reoccurring
bit I really enjoyed I love you saying
look at Dean I love you Sam I love you
dude it's great they never say that to
each other doesn't show but you know
that's the underlying emotion all the
scenes they have with each other
and how different the show would be if
they capped off all the season with yeah
it's like before you go out and hunt
this demon I love you I've said it
before yeah I kind of wish they weren't
brothers because I totally ship them and
ship the [ __ ] I would love for those two
to hook up I think when they reboot
supernatural let's see it's it's ending
now after 15 years so when they rebooted
next year mm-hmm I think they should
make them you know either two gay guys
or sisters adopt woke times I'd say
interracial sisters yep but I the only
thing I noticed about this is no one
thing I noticed about this too though
that was fun was that the bloopers
themselves seemed much more assembled
like they would cut to reaction shots to
sell some of the silly like if they
almost felt like little sketches which
made me wonder were there two cameras
running or did they just take time and
assembling this reel to make some of
these play out as though they would in
the scene they were shooting or
something like that another layer of
energy that was a lot of fun along with
the looseness and the familiarity that
is clearly you can see the family vibe I
assume on this set really developing
also just a lot of fun to have so many
nothing they were the standout moments
necessarily but like so many moments
with the guest stars you know like
Lauren Cullen and Katie Cassidy and even
one or two from Sterling came around I
thought was fun just cuz you usually are
used to the main cast on these things
yeah it always so blows my mind when I
see
how flutes they are and scenes that were
so heavy seriously yeah and in that
moment that someone wants to everything
Kate Browns like its bit right its turn
into a vampire it just looks like the
ant Cameron acting I guess if you're
gonna delve into this ridiculous world
of supernatural entities you gotta have
a sense of whimsy about it even if you
have to be incredibly serious yeah if
you're gonna take something so
ridiculous so serious yeah yeah the back
of your mind you have to be able to poke
a little funny or see some Katie Cassidy
there as well I thought was great she
swears an awful lot she does she's the
most swear honest out of this whole
thing except Bobby he's for one I don't
know I'm gonna get an opportunity to
mention this again on the channel I've
been watching the last season of arrow
and I think she directed this episode of
arrow this is the eighth season of arrow
and this is she gave a performance and
if you guys watch arrow also on the CW
she gave him the best perform she's ever
given on that whole show it was like
great made me cry huh yeah then I've
never been moved by her character that
much and ever before I was catching up
on arrow Wallace or watching
Supernatural I found it really easy to
hop back and forth watching her on this
show and then watching her on arrow like
she's really great at doing two
different portrayals and it does help
that in one show she has blonde hair and
the other she's a brunette so yeah well
that's these days I feel like that is a
more authentic CW experience anyway
because if you ever wind up watching two
shows on that Network chances are you're
gonna see a lot of the same game you
reuse their actors a lot okay you have a
stable and they're just like if you
don't Riverdale yeah go do River does
alright guys well go on our patreon page
if you want to watch our supernatural
reactions over their reaction highlights
included like stated earlier you guys
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell I want to end
this with a patient add a shout out to a
woman named L B because L be you are our
last picture in the day shout out in
October so I figured you should be our
first in November now what I want for
you is for one day to get it on at the
same time with Jared Padalecki and
Jensen Ackles
that way just back and forth you hear
Sam
I'll be yeah and always in that tandem
you got it it's a ritual you can
actually have a roleplay going as though
it is you know a supernatural episode
and you're having some kind of erotic
exorcism so yeah that's what I hope for
you hopefully christmas comes sooner
than later saving people hunting things